depuis
au moins 6 mois l'achalandage a augmenté
à l'urgence avec un taux d'occupation de
130% l'urgence de l'hôtel du de Lévis
est la plus achalandée de la grande
région de Québec les gens savent plus
vers quoi se tourner se présente à
l'urgence le ministre de la Santé
Christian Dubé annonçait cette semaine
la mise en place d'une cellule de crise
elle réunit des PDG de CC dessus et des
experts responsables de calmer le jeu
dans les urgences de Montréal mais en
région aussi les professionnels débordés
auraient aimé en faire partie et la
situation est pas rose non plus à Québec
puis d'en choisir un palace on a besoin
d'une cellule de crise nous aussi en
chaudière à Palace on comprend pas
pourquoi on n'est pas impliqué dans une
cellule de crise la situation elle est
dramatique partout il faut avoir une
vision d'ensemble du réseau pour
l'opposition inclure les hôpitaux
régionaux dans la cellule de crise ne
serait pas suffisant
les administrateurs pour régler la
pénurie de main d'oeuvre alors que les
gens du terrain le disent depuis des
mois et des années qu'ils ont des
solutions à proposer si les gens de
Québec et le milieu du Québec réclament
d'être parti à cette cellule de crise
soit mais encore une fois cette cellule
de crise ne fera pas de miracle
parmi les solutions proposées par les
travailleurs et l'opposition la fin du
temps supplémentaire obligatoire
l'amélioration des services de première
ligne et un meilleur recrutement pour
les postes en santé soit 21 ans que je
suis médecin à l'urgence ça fait 21 ans
qui a des de la congestion dans les
urgences le plus gros problème du
système de santé c'est que les
gouvernements gèrent ça pour être élu
dans 4 heures par courriel le cabinet du
ministre de la Santé Christian Dubé
indique que c'est parce que la situation
est la plus critique dans le Grand
Montréal qu'il se concentre à cet
endroit toutefois les solutions choisies
pour la métropole pourront ensuite être
appliqués à toutes les régions ici
Flavie Sauvageau Radio-Canada Québec